we've now talked a lot about the demand
curve and consumer surplus now let's
look at the other side let's think about
the supply curve and you could imagine
that there might be something called the
producer surplus
so that let's say this is the price axis
this is the quantity axis and let's say
that we are running let's say we are
running some type of a Berry Farm and
this is our supply curve that is the
supply supply curve and this is our
demand curve so that is demand and just
like we did with the supply curve for
the demand curve now instead of thinking
of a price and thinking about how much
quantity would be supplied let's think
about a given quantity and think about
what the price would have to be in order
for the producers to produce that
quantity and so let's say that this
quantity right over here this is in
thousands thousands of pounds of berries
thousands of pounds so this is 1,000
pounds two thousand pounds three
thousand pounds four thousand pounds and
five thousand pounds and let's say that
this price right over here is one dollar
per pound $2 $3 $4 so I could do that a
little bit more even so this is three
dollars this is four dollars this is
five dollars per pound and this is let
me write this this is all in per pound
per pound so let's say that we we want
the suppliers to produce 1,000 pounds of
berries so this is we want them to
produce 1000 pounds of berries what does
the price have to be for them to produce
1000 pounds of berries well think of it
from the suppliers or from the berry
farmers point of view if they're going
to produce 1000 pounds of berries in
order for them to produce it in order to
convince them to produce it they have to
get at Liam as much as they would get
using those same resources to produce
something else
so if they could get if they could get a
dollar per pound or the equivalent in
dollars of $1.00 per pound for those
first thousand pounds so about a
thousand dollars if they could get that
to by producing their
and for an apple orchard or for using it
to to graze or maybe renting out the
land to someone else that's the minimum
you would have to pay them because if
you paid them less than that then they
would do the other thing they would go
and they would go in and and and rent
their land out or they would allow their
land for grazing so you would have to
pay them you would have to pay them the
opportunity cost for them producing
those thousand pounds so the opportunity
cost for them producing those thousand
pounds would be right over there and
this is on average the first thousand
pounds you could also think in that very
first pound the opportunity cost would
be right over there then the next pound
would be right after that the the 500th
pound would be there the thousandth
pound would right be there or you could
say the first thousand pounds on average
would be right over there now let's say
that we wanted them to produce another
thousand pounds so we want the whole
market or this entire farm to produce or
maybe it's multiple farms to produce a
total of two thousand pounds what would
we have to do well same exact thing
we're kind of assuming that maybe the
market is already producing that first
thousand pounds so now we would have to
think about well what are they giving up
to produce that next thousand pounds and
now we would assume that they that for
that first thousand pounds they would
have used the land and the inputs that
are most suitable so this is the most
suitable most suitable resources most
suitable resources so we're talking
about the labor that really knows how to
grow berries the land where berries are
best grown and maybe they're really
close to transportation networks so it's
much cheaper to produce and ship from
there but now if we want another two
thousand pounds of berries in this time
period and maybe this is over you know
this is per year over here if we want
another thousand pounds they're now
going to have slightly less suitable
resources maybe the land that's slightly
further away from transportation
resources there now we're going to have
labor that is slightly less efficient
they're going to have to take land away
from that might have been slightly more
suitable for other things so now the
opportunity cost for these growers for
the next thousand pounds is going to be
slightly higher so their opportunity
cost is going to be like that on average
for the next thousand pounds you could
say the opportunity cost for the one
thousand and first pound will be right
over there
for mm pound would be right over there
but on average for the two thousand
pounds this is their opportunity cost
now same thing the next thousand pounds
after that if we want to get the market
if we want the whole supply to be three
thousand pounds they would have to
produce they would have to get that
their opportunity cost of that
incremental thousand pounds that
opportunity cost of that incremental
thousand pounds and so viewed is it this
way the supply curve no longer and it is
the same exact curve before we to say oh
if we want to if we want to if how much
would people produce if the price were
three dollars you say oh they produce
three thousand pounds now we're looking
at it the other way where we're saying
if we want the suppliers to produce
three thousand pounds what would the
price actually have to be now with that
out of the way now we can think about
the supply curve is really our
opportunity cost curve for the suppliers
and let's say that this is the supply in
the demand and then this would be the
actual price at which supply equals
demand right over there and so let's
just say that that is the market price
so what's going on over here all of the
suppliers so this the price here is just
for making the math simple let's just
say that the price here is $4 and the
quantity demanded and the quantity
supplied here is 4,000 pounds what's
going on here this the very 4,000 pound
the produced by the suppliers the
opportunity cost for them to produce it
would be $4 and they're going to get $4
exactly for it so they're right on the
fence but for the the first three
thousand nine hundred and ninety-ninth
pounds the opportunity cost of producing
it was lower than the price they're
getting so in this situation the
producers are getting more the for the
first three thousand nine hundred ninety
nine pounds they're getting more for
their berries than their opportunity
cost and just like we talked about
consumer surplus this is the producer
surplus so for example for these first
thousand pounds for these first thousand
pounds right here the producers their
opportunity cost was a little over a
dollar a pound but they're getting $4 a
pound for it for the next thousand
pounds the opportunity cost is
approaching two dollars a pound is like
a dollar seventy-five just eyeballing it
once again they're getting $4 a pound
for it so good they're getting this
surplus and so if you think about the
entire market the producers as a whole
they're getting this entire area
this entire area represents the excess
value that they're getting above and
beyond their opportunity cost and recall
this right over here the producer
surplus producer surplus and since we're
assuming or we will assume a linear
supply curve right over here this is
just a triangle finding an area of a
triangle this this length right on this
side is just 4 minus 1 it's just 3 $3
per pound and then this length right
over here is 4,000 pounds 4,000 pounds
so to find the producer surplus we're
just finding the area of this region so
let me write this the producer surplus
here is just going to be I'll use the
same colors three times I want to do is
that pink three three times the four
thousand times the four thousand and
that would give us the area of this
entire rectangle so we have to divide it
by two and if this is just defining the
area of a triangle so times one-half the
same thing as dividing by two and so
this gives us 1/2 times 4,000 is 2,000
times three is six thousand and you can
look at the units it's 6,000 or it's
three dollars per pound times thousands
of pounds per week so we end up with so
the we end up with six thousand dollars
of producer surplus per per week